i've never seen lost but it's a popular
show you asked for it so we're watching
it and i'm grading it based on the level
of misinformation
chess compressions
[Music]
oh no
[Music]
by the way if the engines are spinning
you gotta get out of the way they'll
suck you right in
i wish i had background into the show to
know whether or not he's a doctor he
could be a doctor he's dressed like one
he's trying to help people he's heroic
[Applause]
he knows how to work in teams
interpersonal communication on point
oh crush injuries are quite dangerous
because as soon as you
uh remove whatever the object is on top
of the individual that area gets
reperfused and it can actually cause
more problems
including if you fracture a bone you can
develop something known as a fatty
embolism where a piece of the fat from
the inside of the bone marrow
actually travels to your heart and lungs
causing major problems and potentially
death
smart man get away from the engine
engines can explode
i'm having contractions how many more oh
she's pregnant
eight months okay i don't know oh
someone's doing chest compressions god
awful chest compressions but at least
they're trying i mean he's
lifting the hands off of the person's
chest while doing the chest compressions
that's problematic the hands got to stay
there
and you're not pumping with your elbows
you're pumping with your body and
remember you got to do it 100 beats per
minute
oh no the engine i predicted it i felt
it
oh and it exploded
shards burning uh problems you're gonna
be okay do you understand me
how does he know that the confidence on
these shows astounds me
you've crashed a plane into an island
you don't know where you are you're
lucky to be alive and he's like don't
worry i got this man but you have to sit
absolutely still oh really now well if
she just sits still she'll be fine
she just survived a plane crash hey you
come here i need to get this woman away
from these fumes it's the fumes that are
problematic
if our contractions are currently closer
than three minutes apart call out
call out for him because he's gonna be
able to rescue everybody there's
explosive material flying
and falling from the sky because engines
are exploding but he's like the fumes
stop your head's not tilted far back
enough you're blowing air into our
stomach oh
oh oh how about we don't breathe into
people's mouths anymore
just do the chest compressions in order
to buy time you definitely want to pull
the chin forward because that does make
it uh more accessible like if you're
doing an
ambu bag you actually do want to pull
the chin up like that it helps stairway
come on
come on oh and if you say come on it
actually doesn't help
come on and if you say it twice it also
doesn't help come on
and if you say three times it also
doesn't help
[Music]
oh oh that's a serious
laceration there that's gonna require
some sutures
why didn't why is it not bleeding even
though it's open you know in the
wilderness like this burning that wound
may not be that terrible excuse me
did you ever use a needle i made the
drapes in my apartment
that's fantastic listen do you have a
second i could use a little help here he
said that's fantastic
please stop raising your arm each time
you do that you reopen the wound just
keep it down so that the wound can stay
closed and show her by
rotating look i do it myself i'm a
doctor oh he is a doctor
look at dr jack you know in fact if his
wound is not bleeding out
i would not be in a rush to close it
because
wounds that are dirty and that's
definitely a dirty wound should really
be allowed to heal by secondary healing
meaning that you don't
do a primary closure with sutures
because if you do a primary closure with
sutures you increase the rate of having
an infected wound and he doesn't have
antibiotics that's already problematic i
think i would just kind of clean it out
and allow it to heal by not moving and
letting the area like chill
[Music]
not breathing if a person's
non-responsive and not breathing what do
you do
chest compressions chest compressions
chest compressions
there you go very poor quality chest
compressions i give that a d
minus just because he's at least on the
right spot he's doing them but poor four
bad timing not deep enough all wrong
wrong wrong
breathe charlie come on breathe again
the purpose of doing chest compressions
is to try and revive somebody
not because the chest compressions
actually do something to help revive the
person it just buys them time because it
circulates the blood that's already in
the
vascular system once the arteries
deliver the oxygen to your
body parts and then it's on its way back
there's still a little bit of oxygen
left there so by squeezing the heart by
doing proper chest compressions you're
just
recirculating that blood with its 10 20
of oxygen still left inside of it and
you kind of hope that that blood
circulating
may trigger the heart to restart
it's actually wise to stop at this point
because the brain has been
so long deprived of oxygen that it's
experiencing brain death that even if
you restart the heart the person's not
going to be functional they're not going
to be able to breathe on their own
they're not going to be able to move and
as a result
on an island that equals death or
incompatibility with life
sunny okay some coconuts or something
fell on his head but
that didn't seem like it's too traumatic
remember mechanism of injury sometimes
more important than the injury itself
like when a patient comes in says their
ankle hurts yes i want to look at it but
most importantly i want to know how it
happened
what was the weight did they fall how
far did they fall do they lose
consciousness was it witnessed how long
were they unconscious
all these questions allow us to picture
how much damage actually occurred you're
gonna have to fix it i'm not a doctor
you're a soldier what do people do when
they get wounded
i mean if the cut is right above the eye
do some sort of bandana and tie it
really tight because the rest of skull
is okay
and you can put pressure there it won't
bleed and you'll be okay
[Music]
gunpowder remove the towel and tilt your
head back i as a family medicine doctor
board certified and all have no idea
what's about to happen
[Music]
oh that needs sutures
he's gonna burn it this is not going to
be pleasant is it gonna explode
one two what about the rest of his face
wipe it off first
do not do this at home on an island
anywhere he could have just lit the
match and lit a leaf on fire and like
patted it so at least it cauterized it a
little bit
my guy put gun powder on it like oh
here's some tnt
i hate being sick too what do you think
it is
it's food poisoning what makes you think
that
got some cramping dehydrated nausea
sounds like a gastroenteritis could be
from giardia depends on his stool let's
see if he mentions it you want to lift
your shirt up
[Music]
appendicitis it's your appendix jack
jack so she touched him on the right
lower quadrant like bernie's point
has it ruptured how is he supposed to
know that can you imagine if i walk into
my patient's room hey has your appendix
ruptured
right there there's so fake injecting
him with the lidocaine it's literally
like they're just shooting it on his
skin you actually have to go inside
okay okay try not to move
go just stay still she's cutting his
abdomen just stay
still would you lol
whose x-rays are those outside
those are spinal x-rays and they belong
to a man about 40 years old
and whoever he is he has a very large
tumor on his l4 vertebrae
it's weird that he knows the age i guess
he's looking at how much area in between
the vertebrae they are like if the disc
spaces are preserved
you can't know if that person is 40 30
50 20.
such a wild guess your neck does it hurt
any numbness in your fingers and toes
like
pins and needles when your foot falls
asleep but permanent
because he knows you have a tumor he's
asking about paresthesias you have a
tumor
on your spine an aggressive tumor you
don't know what kind of tumor someone
has on their spine off of an x-ray
you got a biopsy you're not a superhuman
you can't visualize what the tumor is
off an x-ray
you could just see that there's
something abnormal there but it could be
multiple types of tumors if there's a
tumor that's very very
visible that's oftentimes is not the
case maybe you'll see it but you can't
diagnose it you need further image
imaging need further studies biopsies
etc
all right he's going into tacocardia why
what happened is he okay
his blood pressure's dropping should he
be bleeding like that nope
no he shouldn't oh oh that is
not good teamwork i just made a small
incision in ben's kidney stack now if i
don't stitch that back up in the next
hour
he's dead um yeah he's dead now because
i think he's going into v-fib
i don't know what he cut i don't know
what he's doing all this is unethical
not medically accurate this is a joke no
no
put him down up here
what happened there was an accident
fell off a cliff in situations like that
in a trauma you really want to rule out
internal bleeding
because if a person's bleeding
internally they're going to have moments
to live
if that uh because you need to deliver
fluids you need to deliver blood and if
you can't do that on an island i don't
know like
you have no shot basically i'm gonna
need some water shirts
towels anything that i can use to
staunch the bleeding i mean if you're
bleeding on the outside
odds are you're bleeding from the inside
especially with a fall like that so
towels aren't gonna do you much good
his lung just collapsed how does he know
that he didn't
he doesn't have a stethoscope but if you
put his ear to the chest
or he saw that it wasn't rising
symmetrically maybe i'll buy
maybe i'll buy it my guy looked at his
face
and said his lung collapsed jack has
x-ray vision
it's a closed fracture but i can set it
if his leg is turning
blue which it looked like it was you
really should do a reduction where you
put the bone in its correct location
reason being is
if the bone is actively blocking
circulation to the lower foot
once you correct it you can get a
reperfusion injury and die just as a
result of that
who's checking his cervical spine for
fractures they're just like tossing
around his neck
he's blood what blood
transfusion i don't know how he's gonna
do a makeshift iv
i was getting you this a sea urchin
a hollow needle sharp enough to pierce a
noodle
aren't those poisonous
it's perfect what i don't understand is
what is he planning on doing with the
sea urchin spike like is he gonna just
spike the vein and then what
[Music]
these types of transfusions i've never
seen work before i can't imagine that
it's actually working
also i have no idea as he's doing this
transfusion how we know
that he's delivered enough blood does he
know how much blood he's delivering
i'm so used to ordering it uh through a
computer system not just from like all
right let me give him some adequate
amount of blood until i guess i get
dizzy and i pass out like i don't
understand how he's measuring this it's
not working
blood's not the problem that's the leg
all the blood's pulling there
compartment syndrome he didn't get this
injury from a fall
something crushed his leg compartment
syndrome's really problematic because
when you have a crush injury
or really any kind of issue where you're
getting intense inflammation
over a limb and it's circumferential
meaning that it happens all around the
limb it actually starts expanding and
cutting off circulation where necrosis
starts to happen and the treatment for
this is a phaseotomy where you actually
go in and make a cut in order to open
and allow the swelling to come out so
that
the pressure gets off of the arteries
and allows blood to flow again
again this is not surprise to no one
he has internal injuries he's bleeding
internally keep pumping him full of
blood great
that maybe buys him some time but the
reality is as soon as you pump it into
him
he bleeds it right back out internally
this is why if anyone ever has an
abdominal
injury like let's say a stabbing a
gunshot wound you literally have to
open up their abdomen and run their
bowels where you're making sure that
there's no area that your
patient is bleeding out because if your
patient bleeds out and you close them
and you think you're good and they
continue bleeding
they can die but i need you
to push okay
okay okay okay
ready one two
three push yeah go ahead you wanna
time the pushes with the contractions so
when the mom is starting to feel the
contraction come on you ask you confirm
and then you do a push with a count to
ten and then once the contraction's over
you let the mom relax when the
contraction comes back you repeat that
process
i can see i can see the top potential
the baby is crowning
okay and it's ideal that the baby is
coming out head first if the baby's
coming out breech that could be very
problematic
[Music]
get the shoulders out get the shoulders
out
one at a time there's a baby that is not
a newborn
classic with the babies crying good
color probably good apgar scores
[Music]
getting the baby right on mom's chest
perfect form i like it
real dr verse tv doctor i actually share
a lot of my really interesting doctor
patient stories so click on that and as
always stay happy and healthy
you